-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're
all doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating has risen
1 point over the last month.
So now he's going to keep
discovering more and more
classified documents
until he clinches re-election.
The FBI searched
President Biden's Delaware
beach house yesterday
and reported
that they did not
find any classified documents.
Of course not.
You think that's what Joe Biden
reads at the beach?
It's Tom Clancy
or nothing down there.
After facing criticism from
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis,
the College Board yesterday
released a revised framework
for its new A.P.
African-American Studies course,
which no longer
features sections on
reparations, prison abolition,
and black queer studies.
Instead, students will just
watch "Friends."
At a House Judiciary Committee
meeting yesterday,
Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz proposed
that every meeting begin with
the pledge of allegiance,
just like they do
at his girlfriend's school.
The New York groundhog
Staten Island Chuck
did not see his shadow today.
Said residents,
"Yeah, you didn't see nothin'."
During this year's annual
Groundhog Day celebration,
Punxsutawney Phil predicted
another six weeks of winter.
Okay, but did he
see his shadow or a calendar?
Of course winter's not over.
It's February 2nd.
There's still football.
Can we at least move
the stupid ritual
to mid-March,
where there's a little mystery?
The Federal Reserve raised
interest rates yesterday
by a quarter point,
which is going to make it
even harder to get approved
for a loan to buy eggs.
The fast-food chain Subway
has announced
that it will begin slicing meat
in-store in front of customers.
And it can't be a good sign
when your customers' reaction
to your sandwiches is,
"Prove it."
"I'll wait."
Amid reports that the retailer
will file for bankruptcy,
Bed Bath & Beyond
announced yesterday
it will close 87 stores
across the country.
But, remember,
every time God closes a door,
he opens a Spirit Halloween.
And, finally,
a 6-year-old in Michigan
recently ordered
about $1,000 worth of food
on a delivery app while
playing with his father's phone.
Even more impressive,
his wife bought that story.
"I mean, I feel like I should
eat it since it's here."
That was the monologue,
everybody,
and it's off to the races.